so the head of Sudan's ruling Sovereign
Council has fired the leader of the
rapid support forces as his Deputy the
leader of the army
signed a decree on Friday to Sacramento
known as hemeti from the transitional
council with immediate effect we have
Heber Morgan who is joining us from
underman so Heba expands on this a
little bit and tell us what it means and
what could be the implications of this
well the move comes 35 days after the
start of the fighting between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army
here in the capital Khartoum and in
other parts of the country now this
could mean that the general
who's also the head of the sovereignty
council is trying to delegitimize the uh
the position or to minimize the strength
and the significance of the head of the
rapid support forces
who's also known as himeti and it comes
as talks are ongoing between the two
sides even if indirect in the Saudi city
of Jeddah to try to reach a ceasefire
now it is follow it it comes after a
move by General attend to freeze the
accounts of the rapid support forces
many people have been asking why it took
so long to dismiss the vice president of
the sovereignty Council or the head of
the rsf from his position especially
because the Army Chief has already
branded the rsf as a rebel group since
the start of the conflict yet it looks
like he's trying to minimize the
position and the power of the rsf as
negotiations continue and as fighting
continues here in Sudan it's also worth
noting too that while he's dismissed
from function as vice president he is
still a member of the sovereignty
Council which is the ruling body of the
country so it looks more like a move to
try to reduce the power of General
Muhammad and not to completely negate it
right so Hippa tell us what the
situation on the ground is right now as
you know it
there has been a fight against flying
overhead in the cities of Honduran and
in the northern city of bahri with
surface-to-air missiles being fired by
the rapid support forces trying to block
those fights suggests that Sudanese Army
have been flying to Target our step
positions in the capital now fighting
over the past few days has also spread
to the western region of Darfur there
are hundreds of people who've lost their
lives in the fighting between rsf Arab
Allied militias in West R4 and on
Thursday and Friday fighting has resumed
between the rsf and the Sudanese Army we
know that at least a dozen people have
lost their lives in the city of niana in
South Darfur because of the fighting
residents who we spoke to say that they
can hear Heavy Artillery being fired in
the middle of the city forcing many
people to stay trapped in their homes
and the region has already been affected
by years of conflict in the Darfur
region they say that they don't have any
access to medical facilities or to the
market many of them say that they want
to leave South dark for two neighboring
countries or to places that are safer
but because something ongoing fighting
between the rsf and the Sudanese Army in
nyada they can't leave their homes and
they can't leave the states okay thank
you Morgan reporting for us from durman